a Donald Trump's actions so far what has
president-elect Donald Trump done so far
as of today January 23rd let's take a
look first of all President Trump has
filed an executive order minimizing the
economic burden of the Patient
Protection and Affordable Care Act
pending repeal what does this actually
do we're not really sure but it may make
it so that enforcement of that
individual mandate of the Affordable
Care Act is not enforced as strongly in
what we we assume will be a precursor to
the eventual total repeal of Obamacare
Donald Trump has signed Senate bill 81
this is a waiver for defense secretary
James Madison ormally you need to wait
seven years after leaving the military
to become defense secretary and
president Trump has signed a waiver
allowing James maddest to become defense
secretary after only three years out of
the military Donald Trump has also
suspended the mortgage premium rate cut
so what this this is really bad for a
lot of low and middle-income Americans
when you get a new mortgage you
typically put 20% down if you want to
avoid paying what's called PMI private
mortgage insurance and that private
mortgage insurance is pretty expensive
and what has happened here is that a
rate cut that was signed by President
Obama on January 9th set to go into
effect on the 27th has been cancelled by
Donald Trump this makes it more
expensive for poorer and middle-income
people to buy houses this is a really
really bad thing I don't know how this
is making America great again for the
little guy
Donald Trump also has received the legal
okay from the Justice Department for his
son-in-law Jared Kushner to work for the
White House legalized nepotism and
Donald Trump has signed proclamation 1
declaring a national day of patriotism
this does absolutely nothing it will not
be a federal holiday but it will play
pretty well to the Trump ian's into the
hole I'm making America patriotic again
thing which of these items Pat is
setting us back on the path to American
greatness I'm confused I can't think of
one in particular the picture that we
have behind us here is him a
immediately after the inauguration
speaks a speech signing a bunch of
different bills there and you just the
whole time seems quite uninterested in
when he was actually doing yeah it kind
of made me feel the vibe that he was
just a puppet there yeah I had no clue
what it was that he thought he was doing
there because it was everything that
he's been doing has been very very
strange and today apparently he's going
to formally demand that NAFTA be
renegotiated the u.s. pulls out
officially removed the US from TPP
we're expecting things to happen we'll
report on those as they happen here's
what happened so far if you're at rumpus
which one of these day one things that
he did is making America great again let
me know discuss it with us on reddit
david pakman.com slash read it Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
Tryon to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDPS I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like $300 for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing